we are back legs up and you know my next
guest from myself Oh Merry Christmas
everybody
Hey great to see you Santa oh it's great
to see you thanks for stopping by it's
my pleasure
oh so tell us how was Christmas this
year oh just fine wonderful you know
that's a good boys and girls out there
especially you okay so everything
everything went pretty smoothly on
Christmas Eve huh oh yeah things were
wonderful you know Donner and Blitzen
did a great job and Rudolph leading the
way is usual great that's great
so what Santa what do you what are you
up to now
not much got a little downtime no really
you don't have to sort of get started on
you know next Christmas right now get
you know making toys and all that no no
I really got a couple months that I got
to get really back into it you know it's
not till like March or April it uh you
know you start going through the naughty
and nice list could go either way at
this point let's be a little weird
trying to write comedy these days huh
that's a little challenging yeah weird
times yeah yeah they've been weird weird
times I think you got a new set here huh
yeah Santa we got a new set a couple of
months ago it's been here a couple of
months pattern on these furniture will
grab your eye if you're flipping
channels I'll tell you that
I guess so yeah yeah this must have been
one of those TV strategies the
executives upstairs that up on one of
them suits you know what you call them
suits yeah back on the seats yeah you
know Santa I I kind of have to get back
to the show we're doing a show here oh
sure I'm sorry
stay too little listen no doubt see no
more Oh Mary okay that was nice I was a
special treat okay folks you know my
next joke so you're the stage manager
huh
that's right yeah a way to give you them
headphones there so you can you can
listen in and say tell Cohen to slow
down or speed up or down the stretch
beneath all stretch that's a good one
but they see that again shake taffy that
looks fun yeah excuse me Santa I'm sorry
we really are trying to do the show here
so oh sure understood say no more get my
sleigh and I'm on my way Santa Claus
there's only one okay everybody my next
guest tonight what would you like to
play with Springsteen
oh that's great must've been fun huh I
bet it was yeah so uh were you the only
Jewish guy in the band yeah Santa I hate
to be a jerk but you're you're
interrupting oh I'm sorry I was just
talking to max here having some some fun
yeah I hate to do this Santa I'm gonna I
gonna have to ask you to leave oh I see
yeah Christmas is over you got no more
use for Santa Claus huh no no no Santa
it is not like that no I understand
yesterday I'm a big hero and today I get
the old Baltimore boot huh well goodbye
I understand now Santa Santa no wait
Santa don't go we all love you Santa and
we really appreciate all your hard work
during Christmas you can stay all right
if you want to stay you can stay we just
really need you to sort of just be quiet
all right sure sure I'll be quiet you
will one of your people out of me I'm
just gonna go out in the hallway and
take it easy okay in my sleigh and on my
way home Merry Christmas Santa Claus
everybody Santa Claus all right I'm very
sorry about that ladies intimate my next
guest is the star of Law & Order
criminal intent please welcome Vincent
D'Onofrio
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no wonder law and order shirts like what
twelve of them now three three which is
the one where the guy shows his hat oh
that's a good way you should get on that
one that'd be that'd be a good one folks
we'll try this one more time after a
commercial break hopefully Vincent
D'Onofrio will be here